how's it going bros my name is ha we're
playing outlast 2 demo let's just keep
playing [ __ ] hell what was that
licky tongue licky tongue was down here
where I am
[ __ ] I'm soloing batteries shut up
fine shut up I know what I'm doing all
right
oh god you're scared what about me if I
can take over there I think we should
reload the battery that's better
okay here yes this is good fun man I'm
enjoying this just as long as no one
nothing pops up in my bed you know what
I mean [ __ ] this man those bolts gonna
hurt laughing what's this this is where
I came from
oh great I went in circles [ __ ] you
you're not scared
am i the only ones sweating like a
[ __ ] pool balls don't sweat I know
that but shut up okay Jesus why you
gotta be so loud man
oh my god I'm fine fine I'm fine I'm
fine
who's late for class
booty pie teacher up up here - where
where am I
let's go that's bright Arizona that's
alright that's another place I will
never go - thanks thanks video game
batteries in the mountains gun and you
can't go on oh man it feels weird feels
weird to be back man alright great we
can't go there that's just fan [ __ ]
taste again a Catholic school the way to
success no it's going great so far for
you guys oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] it alright
well I guess we just go down the creepy
dark heart holy wait now what time is it
oh [ __ ] is way back my bedtime
oh I can hide in the lockers this is
just like high school what the [ __ ] man
I didn't ask for this
Oh God who's laughing [ __ ] I'm a bunny
I'm a bunny all right
you can't hurt a bunny no one would ever
hurt a bunny
all right no one would ever touch a cute
Jessica just just go what when we were
two Jessica can't read that what is this
a music smell Jessica's yeah when I play
it well that was fun let's never do that
again what I like a code whoo what the
[ __ ] was that
Oh get me out of here man get me the
[ __ ] out of here I'm running out of
batteries [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] what stop doing the shadow
thing [ __ ] you and your shadow thing I
got full better shut up
you're not even the real launcher oh god
okay this is too much for me man I can't
I can't [ __ ] do this [ __ ] anymore I
don't want it just get me the out how
the [ __ ] do I get out of this piece of
[ __ ]
this place sucks Peter past sucks
buddy Jay says what the [ __ ] was that
thing there's some fine ass [ __ ] man
[ __ ] came out of nowhere
[ __ ] oh my god I should play this with a
heartbeat so we can go through Jessica's
Locker whoa what the [ __ ] man I really
should play this a heartbeat monitor
that'd be cool maybe I'll do that when
the full game is that excuse me I broke
when I'm excited miter doesn't
appreciate it I know but
[ __ ] me man this is not good breasts
oh my god it's one of these did you
breasts have these in school you know
when the teacher excuse me I'm trying to
talk to my breasts when the teacher
pulled one of the all right you know I
[ __ ] you all right I'm coming all right
Jessica or Lynn whatever your name is oh
okay no that's great that's funny
because I was actually heading this way
towards the exit yes okay well I guess
we'll have to take this rad huh that's
oh come on
whoa it's licky tongue again that
[ __ ] pokemon scat may see a [ __ ] is a
[ __ ] he got me [ __ ] oh my go
oh my god oh god oh look out they're
after me oh god where do we go where do
I go [ __ ] fool man oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I'm a corn I'm a corn I swear to god I'm
of corn I love corn so much okay here we
go
here we go good here oh I'm over oh
thank god good I'll put it here - oh
[ __ ] I'm so [ __ ]
I am so exhausted oh my glasses put on
your glasses put any glasses
Oh
oh my god
Oh all right great we're gonna go
through a full game of this press if
you're excited for the full game leave
it like and I'll check it out for sure
thank you so much for watching really
appreciate it we're gonna go on a new
adventure together unless you're too
scared you're too scared I have no right
to say that I'm sorry I brush as always
stay awesome dress